game text back with yet another graphic
settings explainer and based on a number
of comments from our previous videos we
figured that ambient occlusion would be
best to dive into next so we have
anti-aliasing to get rid of jaggies and
isotopic filtering to clean up them
textures or your game still may look a
little flat
well let's bring ambient occlusion out
of the shadows to show you what it does
[Music]
before we go any further hit that
subscribe button to keep up with game
tag here at GameSpot ambient occlusion
is a calculation of how much an object
or surface is blocked from environmental
light sources it accounts for everything
around these objects and the position
relative to each other and whether the
ambient light comes from it then
simulates where light should not be
present
thus crevices and corners where light
technically doesn't reach are darkened
the result shadowing that adds a richer
and more realistic looks to the overall
environment it creates more depth to an
otherwise flat picture here's what I
mean pay close attention to the spaces
around the water-jug the corners of the
shelving units the items stored on low
shelves and where the wall meets the
floor with ambient occlusion you'll
notice that the shadows around these
objects are more lifelike and add more
depth to the environment ambient
occlusion isn't true shadow rendering or
tied to the shadow settings in your
games but it's much more efficient than
global illumination which would analyze
each pixel and light source to create
the shadowy effect however ambient
inclusion can still be taxing on your
hardware now there are a few different
methods of how ambient occlusion is done
to go through the most common ones
in-game but it all started with the
perennial first-person shooter that
pushed pcs to the limit a decade ago
screen space ambient occlusion or SSAO
was first introduced with the original
Crysis from Crytek's
sees the CryEngine it's the basic level
of ambient occlusion darkening areas
that are blocked from the environmental
light source these shadows are
represented at half resolution so it's
not as detailed as it could be still it
was advanced for its time horizon based
ambient occlusion or HB AO from Nvidia
and High Definition ambient occlusion or
HD AO from AMD take things to the next
level in
increases the number of samples used
when calculating the areas that should
be darkened and renders at full
resolution for a more accurate
representation of ambient occlusion but
as a result it's even more taxing on
your system
HP ao+ is an advanced version of regular
h Bao that you'll see in more modern
games since it's a more efficient form
again the number of sample views to
create the shadows is increased while
generally having less of a performance
impact than old H Bao it's still more
demanding than ssao fossil accelerated
ambient occlusion or VX AO is the most
advanced form today and it's very
performant heavy nvidia says it's about
three to four times slower than HP AO
plus but it doesn't make any graphical
compromises and it looks amazing
it affects larger portions of the games
environment and accounts for objects
that aren't necessarily in view but
would contribute to ambient occlusion
anyway it's still in its early stages
but it can be seen in Unreal Engine 4
with Rises a Tomb Raider I would highly
recommend using some form of ambient
occlusion if you can afford the
processing power its overall impact on
the visual appeal of a game strongly
felt but it also depends on what you're
playing maybe a fast-paced shooter where
framerate matters most doesn't need it
but an immersive sim like prey or
Dishonored 2 where you're carefully
inspecting the environment will look
much more believable with ambient
occlusion and as always make sure your
system can run the settings just fine
this was the fourth in a series of PC
graphics settings explainers so I want
to ask you what we should demonstrate
next so hit up those comments and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
all that good stuff thanks for watching
and we'll see you then